about my patience is wearing thin what  you're talking to  as long as your patients don't get as  thin as that hairline i think we'll be  all right i am not your child  yeah what and i'm showing up natural  you're talking about your patience is  wearing this these people have lost they  acting like they you know what i'm  saying i'm saying like they paying your  bills and you down you got to watch you  i saw that little clip i said oh he's  crazy  he really think he you really think i  miss her  my patience is wearing thin i need you  to get out on that boulevard and bring  me my money yeah my pimp  the hell is wrong with these people he  really said that [ __ ] out of his mouth  but our patience is wearing thin you  bald hip see see  see i'm trying i thank god see that  danny calling me right now trying to  stay trying to save my mind  i could not have said it better myself  where do i vote for that woman where do  i give me a mail-in ballot